endlich hat der deutsche staat mal
knallhart durchgegriffen
ein tag vor beginn der pfingstferien
wurden an deutschen flughäfen dreiste
kleine schulschwänzer von der polizei
erwischt und erschossen entschuldigung
ermahnt vom neu gegründeten bundeswehr
schutz ist ein neues sek so dass mal
sinnvoll angelegtes steuergeld für nicht
und schuld waren wie immer die eltern
sehr klar weil der billigflug nach
barcelona einen tag vor den ferien drei
euro weniger kostet in alle ihre immer
öfter und immer preiswerter reisen ist
ein weltweiter trend und dieser trend
hat folgen an vielen wochenenden sind
die billigflieger randvoll mit party
touristen wissen sie da ist es im
unwahrscheinlichen fall eines
stimmungsabfall fangfrische bierdosen
von der decke das kann leben retten
so und die ureinwohner an beliebten
reisen sowie über pfingsten die können
einen echt nur noch leid tun
in venedig zum beispiel das hier ist
unsere aktion um die leute davon
abzuhalten auf die straße zu wissen es
nicht auf die straße
sonst film wir dich und du bist bei
youtube und dann kann jeder sehen die
kleinen dein penis ist oder wie groß
eine chance
doch genug verliert anderes beispiel
amsterdam amsterdam da möchte man auch
nicht mehr wo 900.000 einwohner aber 18
millionen touristen pro jahr oder berlin
genauso schlimm 13 millionen touristen
wenn in städte wo ohnehin wohnungsnot
herrscht auch noch besuchermassen
einfallen
dann werden die touristen irgendwann zu
einer erbin biblischen plage diesem
board spieler im sechs autoren eine
woche gearbeitet
ferienwohnungen bringen dem vermieter
viermal so viel kohle die normale
mietverhältnisse das ist das problem und
airbnb macht natürlich auch echt clevere
werbung muss man zugeben
da sieht man dann was die kunden auf der
ganzen welt für tolle aussichten haben
beim blick aus der wohnung nichts blöder
tourist oder lebst du quasi in der
fremden stadt ist voll urban ja leider
sieht die realität anders aus hier das
sehe ich wenn ich zu hause aus meinem
fenster gucke dank airbnb
[Applaus]